go for it what's that ballers welcomes
real mature just spilled water on myself
anyhow real mature is a show that we
make about things that happen to you
when you grow up and one of the things
that happens when you grow up is your
relationship with your friends changes
so we have three different stories about
friendship today one of them involves a
lie what should I say just saying hey
hey cool please get into one thing that
we were thinking about when we were
talking about friendship it asks a
question to a bunch of the people who
work on this show do you know why your
friends like you like do you guys know
why your friends like you no no no
really
like do you ever thought about it or
thought to ask them all right no I just
make it weird I feel like oh you would
make it weird what we did is we
interviewed three of Ella's friends in
three different parts of her life and we
asked what do you like about Ella why do
you want to be friends with her the
first person we interviewed was a new
friend of yours mm-hmm - Leigh crossing
from like calling someone this is my
work friend - my friend friend like
that's a weird thing I think to grown up
saying that out yeah okay go on you
ready watch yeah I met Ella about a
actually it was almost two years ago we
didn't become friends until like six
months ago
you remember what your first impression
was oh she's really nice and chill but
kind of quiet which is hilarious to me
now identity have like a lot of thoughts
and I'm really opinionated and I don't
want people to think I'm a [ __ ]
honestly really say yeah so I definitely
hold myself at I remember being like I
want to be friends with Ella but not
knowing exactly how to wait so you had
like a friend crush yeah get a friend
crush on her as well yeah she's awesome
what she's passionate about she's so
intense and then the rest of her life is
just so [ __ ] chill people they're
like you're just you're chill you just
have a chill personality and I'm like
cool I'm glad you think that it's
interesting just like watching this now
the thought I just had is the things
that your friends like you for it are
the things that people who don't
like you yeah for it is weird to say
like the thing I don't like about her is
that she doesn't like herself enough
sometimes and it's like dude you're
super cool like just be proud of that
and be into that's why people like you
thank you yeah it's true I don't know
why I'm so critical of myself but it's
it's awesome to hear that and it just
makes me feel so much better
okay well we're gonna look at a couple
more of your friends what they had to
say but first off we're gonna go see our
friend Abe who has another story for us
but he's in another building so we got
to go get on so guys ready yeah y'all
ready ready to it all right
what's up babe hello you ready to tell
us about brunch I am ready yes come here
let's do it Hey I'm dying so we're not
weird no I like being summoned from my
editing booth good to stand up every now
and then you're working on a pretty long
documentary the longest we've made in a
while about one of our colleagues Matt
and like a super interesting friend that
he made yeah it's a totally unique
friendship I don't think anything like
this has never happened before what
happened was Matt lost his phone a year
later in his iCloud he started to see
photos from the person who had his old
phone he were to post about like seeing
those photos on his phone and that
became a wildly successful story in
China and the Chinese internet been
found the guy and there was this
incredible internet pressure for them to
meet and then once they met they became
friends yeah so you have a piece now
that is just a segment of the film about
when they realize they were friends what
do you think about Colin I like it cool
cool all right all right well let's
watch this piece all right so right now
we're in the East Village I live in the
East Village so this is literally where
I had my phone taken basically my phone
went from where we are right now
to China to southern China
like like random southern China
- brother orange
I just really open to everything we
cancelled all of our hotel reservations
because they told us to
anywho what's going to happen
we're just I'm talking through an app
that translates for me to him and we're
talking through Chinese Twitter what
she's speaking in Chinese on and then I
asked people I said hey can you help me
translate that like that's like the way
that we're communicating I have no idea
what's about to happen right now oh my
god magic just like waving to people
wait why I can do China yeah
thank you I think I'm gone you know I
don't go ah how's it go Matt
a tarantula why is our momentum tonight
I see men demand general Arjuna you can
pop it up CJ just yeah meet each other
it's always so amazing it's bizarre it's
really bizarre brother orange is a
really nice guy genuinely it's been less
than 24 hours but I feel like I say I
was with him for like a month I feel
like we would have much of social cues
by then
he's like his big brother taking the cap
oh I feel more of a connection to
brother orange what kind of guy is mad
what is he like
say m'lady Tashi young wallah
are we gonna do I don't know we're hands
on in Atlanta and young Chui Neela
individual I'm you know here we have fun
with each other without words you can
still have fun and laugh at things and
you know you notice things in your point
in you'll be like look at that thing
that's communication right there and
that's how we communicate yeah I don't
know he's just a really fun guy hey
pizza sleep and you know as time warp it
has she been Toula oh yeah yeah Visio
Nagar
Wow Wow huh
and it's funny because we've moved on in
a relationship your brother orange or
comfortable with awkward silences and so
we'll be just like sitting and no one
will feel pressure to say anything which
is honestly if everyone knows that's the
first step to a friendship is when you
don't have to say anything we don't
speak the same language and still I feel
this honest month from him honest we are
like legitimately friends the Chinese
really believe in you know faith and
good luck for some reason I meant to
come here and some reason orange brother
was meant to meet me and there's some
weird fake thing whether that's just I'm
were meant to just go through this
amazing experience and I'm not saying
like this is going to be something's
going to happen because of it it's just
that we were meant to go have this
amazing experience together when do you
feel like you knew that you and Matt
were truly friends the institution
decisions shortened abba-zaba low shun
Sakura to vote sabudana vada
nuts and candy to show Toby Pisciotta
ever be
so party system entire bad bad bad bad
man
why
so when's the form of yummy done I am
working on it
like about you are ya wait wait wait I
got a good bit right there
okay you know what Abe stands for right
well I always be editing that's not
gonna make it okay all right but yeah I
always be it same with the story of
brother orange reminds you of is a the
idea that like a lot of the friends you
make you make by like going through an
experience with somebody and so we have
another friend of yours who were going
to watch talk about how she became
friends with you and you guys went
through the experience of college
together what do you think she's gonna
say no good college I have no idea
all right ready yoga good head moment
good okay
I met Ella through college um we were
potluck suitemates the fact that you're
skating with one friend Tyra yeah we're
drinking a beer just like hearing about
my life I knew she was really cool and I
wanted to be friends with her so I'm
glad that we um sort of became friends
and stuck together Olive College we
continue to live together until she
moved to LA
wait so you saw her on Facebook and
you're like she's cool yeah yeah I
looked through all her profile pictures
and I was like I'm gonna get along with
this girl you have a friend pushes on me
that's so crazy because I don't think
anyone wants to be friends with me she's
definitely not afraid of people she's
not afraid of being herself or tossing
out a really quirky idea but she's also
one of the most laid-back people that
I've ever met she kind of just rolled
out of bed and she's that cool do you
think if you met today just add a bar
like your face is like two friends
groups sort of like meeting together and
you guys started talking do you think
you would hit it off
what do you think she's gonna say I
don't know okay
see what she says yeah for sure my name
is Maggie happy
this is a joke guys I don't think
sweating
the next video we're going to watch is
one that Colin may so Colin once you
tell us your story I moved to Los
Angeles about a year ago and I'm I was
30 years old I didn't really know
anybody and it was the first time in a
very long time that I had to make some
friends so Henry told me to make some
friends and I did it the best I knew how
how I put up some fliers my mom didn't
like this idea very much she said it
seemed kind of dangerous but it only
took about 20 minutes before I started
meeting other people on the street and
of course they were making a video too
I'm Jenny break the wall so I followed
these two guys around the corner to a
building that I actually thought was
abandoned and it's not but well I guess
I kind of sound sketching out I say it
out loud this is the same just gonna
play it out like it was all planned
actually BuzzFeed came into it jump with
Ryan yeah our our studio is it's always
been
I was feeling pretty confident my plan
at this point I mean I didn't really do
anything and I was already getting tours
of big cool art studios and jumping on
trampolines
nice to meet you and you found me on
Instagram yeah okay great little thing
sweet all right to the lake wave Jenny I
started getting a little cocky with my
skills introduce myself to this channel
hey this is Andrew hey people we met
Andrew while he was eating breakfast
yeah cuz he was getting a late start
today yeah there's probably like people
sitting around everywhere who are like
oh man I'm chef when people hang out
right you know who are thinking the same
thing you wanted the same thing really I
think it's you have to be sort of opened
a new possibility we show you how to add
it for an hour I feel like an idiot
heatstroke Andrew and I had a lovely
afternoon and I went home thinking my
day was over but when I checked my email
I discovered that my flyers were
actually working I'm trying to pick out
a beer cuz I got invited to a potluck
tonight love
hey oh and get up here man nice to meet
you nice to meet you too that's JP he's
saw one of my fliers by the lake how are
you come on in
thanks you guys how do you all know each
other's we're gonna pull pork sandwiches
guys
just bros meet and videogames I totally
forgot how much I miss this kind of
thing I think Sophie it's pretty bold
for a woman to call on a flier but after
a couple beers and a few tacos we both
got a little more comfortable with each
other and started talking a bit about
friendship and what it really means and
then when we got on the subject of
making friends as an adult thank you she
said something that really struck a
chord with me
and I haven't really forgotten about it
I guess the hardest part about making
friends is admitting that you want to
make new friends because you feel like
when you're an adult you should already
have friends and you should have already
found your place in the world but really
you
what's going on at all and that's okay
right there that's when she nailed it
and she's right the only thing that
really gets in the way of making new
friends is ego I mean nobody really has
this [ __ ] figured out so I decided to
start calling back the new friends I've
made because I realized that that was a
lot scarier than meeting new people
meeting new friends was starting to feel
easy and that's when I got a call from
Jesse and Echo Park native who was
looking for a sofa in Craigslist and
found me instead
after a few tacos we hit it off
immediately if I need it I'll get a
haircut
right there Casanova here you go yeah I
learned something important from all my
new friends I realized that it's just
not that weird to call a friendly
looking dude on a flyer
it pays to just put yourself out there
and you know make the connection because
I Drive a moped and yeah I Drive a moped
new friends have perks
all right so speaking of friends are you
ready to watch one of your oldest
friends Julie has known me through
different periods of my life she's not
any the longest of me yeah
so it'll be interesting to see if she
has a similar view of me
I met Ella in seventh grade I don't
remember my first impression she was
kind of quiet kind of like the weird
girl in the corner she's a weird girl in
the corner yeah but I kind of was too so
I think that's why we clicked what do I
look quiet weird open I think one of my
first memories of hers in school we were
playing with large large water bottles
of course she's gonna tell this story
this is I I think about this a lot it's
when I smacked her in the face at the
bottle and she started crying right a
water jug exactly and she ended up
smashing me in the face with one of them
so I was like my first real memory of
Ella it was me being a team of
coordinators I'm sorry I remember just
being like well I'm never gonna have
friends again
because my new friend is crying now and
she'll hate me forever what do you like
about Ella as a person the first thing
that came to my mind is her
impulsiveness she just decided she wants
to do something she doesn't overthink it
and she does it I want to note that this
is I think the third person who has
called you impulsive yeah I never
thought that about myself
what is your friendship look like in 20
years uh gonna be friends forever yeah
whether that's long-distance friendship
like we've done in the past I saw their
friend crush on her you start afresh
okay I still want to be her friend
you feel closer to your friends now that
we did this one I feel like I really
know more about myself
just from what they are saying it's
amazing to hear that they really do like
me for who I am and want to be friends
with me
remember that friendship is a process
and you'll be better if you're like
intentional about it and actually think
about your friends as opposed to just
like going through life taking
friendship for granted
kids babe babes friends putting in a
wish to wrap it up thank you guys for
watching what it do what after this
episode of real mature was produced by
the BuzzFeed IRL team including me Ryan
be Colin Abe and Michelle thanks to
bureaucratic CMA Music and Ducato for
the beats Jesse for the graphic help and
everyone who was in the video